Oh ed Harris you never let me down west
world time and this time we've got
episode four the riddle of the Sphinx
and I like this oh it's funny I'm
normally I try and get my recordings
done like right after I watch it in this
case I was dead tired after I watched it
so I actually slept on it I'm recording
this the next day and I'm really glad
for that because the more I thought
about it the more I like this thing yeah
boy what do we even start
okay so despite the fact that I had
thought initially we were just getting
straightforward flashbacks again we're
still getting some interesting little
ins and outs and bendings of time and
flashbacks and things between the stuff
that we get with William which is what
I'll use to term the younger version of
the man in black and you know the adult
version the man in black and and Jim hid
the the guy who ran the company that he
effectively took over and then again
with some of the flashes of Bernard and
him trying to piece together what's
going on I really like that revelation
well back up LGBT live is weird to me
like I honestly didn't know what to feel
about that because I I remember liking
her and feeling kind of bad that she got
I thought killed off in the first season
um yet I didn't feel anything when it
was revealed she's actually alive so I
honestly don't know what to make of that
but I do like a lot of what came out of
it I Chi Chi is being played well her
reactions are they feel genuine they
feel earned and so we we've got Bernard
and I love what she says to him which is
that your mind isn't distinguishing your
memories properly you remembering stuff
but not the order of them you can
remember that this was the thing that
happened or that you saw but you won't
know if this happened before this or
this and I
did the exactly were to you she said it
way more succinctly than I just did but
I loved that as a new device and a new
way for the show to mess around with
time and narrative a little bit which is
just yeah I dig that I love the man in
black and Lawrence I mean I loved them
together last season when they were
almost entirely you know semi
antagonistic towards each other
now that it feels like there's really
becoming a bond between the mostly of
what I when I say that I mean Lawrence
towards the man of black because I feel
like the man of black had an affection
towards him I kind of a weird twisted
affection towards him even previous to
this but you know he was a guy who kept
getting killed and reset and you know so
Wow
well Ed Harris as the man in black might
have some affection towards him this
guy's a blank slate every single time he
runs it he runs into him so seeing that
play out I think it's it's good that we
sort of dealt with the loose end of the
guys that Delores had double cross
because I'm not sure there was anything
interesting to be milked out of out of
them so that said I do I do think that a
couple episodes ago it was a good thing
that Teddy let them go cuz I I'm hoping
we'll get some interesting stuff milked
out of that but actually dealing with
him as a character who's still alive
let's clear him off the board they did
and in a very entertaining way felt good
felt cathartic boom loved it so it's
funny with William in the first season
he was one of the weaker elements but
honestly it was only because until
almost the end of this first season you
didn't know why he was there you didn't
know why he was included he just kept
going back to him go why are we going to
this less interesting young guy over and
over again and then by the end you
realize oh and now every time we see him
you know as a younger man we know who he
is we know who he becomes and it makes
him immediately more interesting to
watch and I'm not checking my checking
you know the time going oh this guy
again I'm going
what more are we gonna learn about him
and we get I think a really fascinating
new wrinkle with this whole thing with
Jim and this host that they very clearly
tried to put a dead person's mind in a
functional way into a host body that's
new I mean we we had elements of living
people put into characters most notably
with elements of Arnold being put into
Bernard but Bernard is not a literal
recreation of Arnold he's not everything
that Arnold was and he doesn't believe
himself to be Arnold Jim they that's
what they're trying to do um and it's
funny because I figured out that that's
what was going on almost immediately
like as soon as William handed him that
piece of paper I'm like that's got the
conversation they're having right now on
it and the show wouldn't confirm that
for a little bit but I still like how
that panned out because I like what I
like about this is this the kind of
twist that on paper I usually hate
because usually when this kind of twist
is done it ends up you know somehow
rewriting what came before and then it
usually is played as and this is what
was really going on the whole time which
often means that whatever we were shown
before we might as well have not had any
investment in because it wasn't what we
thought it was something else that we're
only now starting to understand so you
feel like you just wasted however long
before this revelation came on this is
not that though and the reason is is
that in this case this revelation that
they're trying to do this with the hosts
in no way undercuts subverts or
diminishes what we have seen hosts like
Dolores Maeve and and all these other
and Clementine all these other
characters going through they their
journey their change their growth is all
still valid this is something else
happening in addition to it so it does
go oh forget everything you knew it's
really this it instead it's yeah there's
all that stuff you knew there's also
this this is going
- which is it's great because like I
said this kind of big revelation usually
derails these narratives at least for me
but it doesn't here and it really makes
me interested and then got the flashes
of Bernard and it's weird because
Jeffrey right is so sympathetic and has
been in this part the entire time is
playing it but the look on his face
stepping on that guy's head I'm like oh
okay
oh man I'm really curious to see how
this um how this pans out and plays out
and I'm not totally sure that I have my
head wrapped around exactly what I saw
but man I'm fascinated by it like I want
to know how that like time wait where
that it where that happened where the
timing on that is was that something
that happened very recently because it
certainly looks like that but you know
was it a while ago was there a reset
between them not like what what is this
what happened I'm I I'm excited to find
out we've got little hints that they
might be doing what I need them to do
with the ghost nation which is to give
them some depth we've got that at the
very least some hints to that I'm
because we have one of the guests saying
how young she turns out she knows their
language more or less and she makes a
comment about how no one ever pays
attention to their narratives and I'm
really hoping that that's gonna go
somewhere and cuz it was also pointed
out that they weren't killing guests
they were killing other hosts so I'm
really looking forward to see what other
details we get about them because I
mentioned before I needed something else
cuz right now they were kind of really
really one side of really generic and
I'm just like everything in this episode
is stuff that works viscerally and or
sets up stuff that I'm like yeah give me
more that please so yeah I like this
episode a lot and I almost never talked
about this the the next time on stuff
but Maeve we had no Maeve this episode
which you know Maeve's awesome
we're getting Maeve next time looks like
there's gonna be so much Maeve and may
even samurais and yeah yeah I'll take it
so yeah riddle of the Sphinx I like it a
lot of kind of giddy on it yeah
you folks seen it would you think about
it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it I can be supported on patreon
if you want to try and help make the
show better if that is even possible
cuz it's already perfect no I mean more
like how much better can I be boy I'm
now I'm under selling it now no one's
gonna want to support me yeah I got to
stop talking and like that so there's
also Twitter and I have a podcast and
t-shirts are for sale etc etc it said a
links for all that stuff down in the
description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]